voy a construir una sucesión empezando
por un número un número digamos que es
el número a muy bien y cada término
sucesivo se va a obtener multiplicando
el anterior por un número fijo r
entonces por ejemplo el siguiente
término sería este a pero x r
el siguiente término tendría que ser
este anterior que es r por r así que
tengo a r por r que es r cuadrada quién
sería el siguiente término sería este de
aquí a r cuadrada a r cuadrada pero x r
nos da aire al cubo y así sucesivamente
vamos construyendo esta progresión y que
justamente por esta razón le vamos a dar
un nombre específico y se le conoce como
sucesión o progresión geométrica
esto es una progresión progresión
geométrica muy bien cómo se hace uno
como construye uno una progresión
geométrica empiezas en cualquier número
que te guste digamos no sé tres cinco
diez mil el que tú quieras y después vas
construyendo poco a poco los siguientes
multiplicando por un número fijo el que
tú quieras ok es el número fijo también
tiene un nombre especial este número ere
por el cual multiplicamos cada vez que
queremos obtener un nuevo número de esta
progresión tiene nombre y se llama es
conocido como la proporción común la
proporción común de una progresión
geométrica y esto porque es cierto bueno
esencialmente la proporción entre
cualesquiera dos términos de esta
sucesión que sean consecutivos digamos
tómense este y tómense el que le sigue
si nosotros dividimos esos dos
calculamos la proporción que tienen
digamos
r al cubo / / a por ere cuadrada a por
ere cuadrada
si nosotros calculamos esta razón o esta
proporción bueno esto se cancelan se
hacen uno y tenemos r al cubo entre re
cuadrada
esto es r y esto va a pasar para
cualesquiera consecutivos verdad porque
vamos a tener a r a la equis potencia
entre a er a la equis menos un potencial
as a se cancelan y tenemos r a la equis
entre r a la equis menos son entonces
nos queda de verdad así que esto va a
pasar para cualesquiera así que por
ejemplo vamos a dar vamos a dar un
ejemplo de una progresión geométrica
digamos no sé quizás empiezas con un
número digamos el 5 este va a ser el
primero y digamos que nuestra proporción
común va a ser un séptimo entonces cuál
sería el siguiente término pues cinco
por un séptimo que es 5
entre 7 muy bien cuál sería nuestro
siguiente término ahora este de aquí lo
tenemos que multiplicar por un séptimo
así que nos queda 5 entre 7 por 7 que
son 49 muy bien ahora este término de
aquí para obtener el cuarto término
tenemos que multiplicarlo por un séptimo
entonces tendremos 5 entre 7 por 49 eso
es bueno eso ya es más complicado 9 por
7 son 63 llevamos 6 7 por 4 son 28 y 6
son 34 así que tenemos 343 y así podemos
seguir indefinidamente muy bien entonces
esto fue un ejemplo de una progresión
geométrica con razón común o con
proporción común un séptimo muy bien
ahora vamos a ver otro ejemplo
digamos que tenemos esta progresión esta
sucesión 36 12 24 y quizás algunos de
ustedes ya vieron de qué se trata y 48 y
esta continúa de la misma forma ok la
pregunta es si esto es una progresión
geométrica entonces para ver si es una
progresión geométrica debemos ver que
para cualesquiera dos consecutivos su
proporción es constante y de hecho es la
misma verdad por ejemplo tomemos este de
aquí y este de acá entonces 12 entre 6
vamos a hacer esta división 12 entre 62
así que hay que multiplicar por 2 a 6
para llegar al 12 pero fijémonos que el
12 hay que multiplicarlo por 2 para
llegar al 24 y el 24 hay que
multiplicarlo por 2 para llegar al 48 de
hecho también el 3 hay que multiplicarlo
por 2 para llegar al 6 entonces de hecho
sí
es una progresión geométrica tiene una
proporción común y es el 2 verdad y
entonces claramente esto es una
progresión geométrica así que aquí no es
que estemos multiplicando primero por 2
luego por 3 luego por 10
y demás sino que claramente esto es una
progresión geométrica porque siempre
multiplicamos por el mismo número para
obtener el número siguiente